remember this is it like that with chess
are you like remember this opening
remember that move and then that
wouldn't move
or or do you just think about this is
the opening i'm going to play i think in
an ideal world you would already have it
all mapped out you'd planned it far in
advance just like with exams but usually
chess plays they stress out about it
until the last moment at least i do and
meanwhile the game has kicked off it's
the spanish opening the royal lopez the
move is coming very very fast and we've
seen this plenty of times from magnus
carson before including during the world
championship match and during the world
championship match he was usually
bringing the black rook across one
square in this position and this is what
we and there we go the rook does just
sidestep any potential pressure on the
a-line and this is what we call the
anti-martial
it's avoiding the marshall gambit named
after the american player frank marshall
and this position arose plenty of times
in that famous clash between the pontiac
and carson giri must have done his
homework here magnus knows pretty much
everything there is to know about this
position it's very interesting because
magnus was relying on this to retain the
world championship and anisha's had all
the time in the world to try and find
something from the white perspective
knowing that he must win this uh this
game so it really really is a battle of
preparation um can he break magnus down
i mean
i i i thought after the world
championships the consensus was
generally that uh black's a little bit
worse in these positions but you can't
beat magnus in them
that's that's basically what what i
gathered you know that magnus is kind of
like
he's done his work and he knows that
these positions are just about
manageable um but we will see yeah and
what's exciting about anish's team is
that they're quite young and they're
always providing fresh ideas so i'm
looking forward to seeing
what they've taken from the world
championship match and uh how are they
going to pose magnus some problems and
this is why magnus actually varies from
his move that he played in the world
championship there he actually picked up
his h-pawn moved at one square now he's
developing his light square bishop
yup and this is why magnus likes these
positions so much it's exactly as you
said simon black has a small
disadvantage and will do for the next 10
15 moves but you're super flexible
you're super solid you have options on
every turn in terms of varying your move
order and it's extremely hard for white
to find a knockout blow something direct
and if there's nothing direct then
slowly that advantage might fizzle out
from the white side so i'm personally a
bit surprised that anish has gone for
this in a situation where he really does
want to win uh it just feels like you're
playing on your opponent's home turf yes
objectively according to a computer as
we see the evaluation bar um you might
have an advantage it might say plus
plus 0.5 it might might even say plus
one but in terms of practical play your
opponent is super solid your opponent
knows all the defensive plans and
it's going to be hard to break through
later so we will see but meanwhile early
days in this opening battle
i feel the nerves for anish geary and
for many of these players who are
fighting to qualify for the knockout and
obviously
everyone's dependent on all the other
games i'm not even sure if they can see
the other games while they're playing in
online chess i think they're allowed in
these tournaments to go and check
but it does take a while um it does take
a while to do that normally when i've
played in these types of tournaments
you're allowed to have one browser open
just your your game nothing else but i
think for players they are allowed other
windows just to check the uh rival games
that's the only way they know how to
make decisions whether to take a draw
whether to exactly
yeah but usually the players they don't
do that they just focus on their own
games yeah the time control of course is
usually they won't have time anyways
when it's getting into those critical
moments all right
few moves here yep a couple of moves and
again but there's very logical plans
from both sides white bringing the
knight out and black occupying a square
with his knight that cannot at least
temporarily get kicked away and white's
knight retreating out the way in order
to create a square for a white pawn to
kick back the black knight from his half
of the board this is still pretty
standard stuff uh but magnus at least
gaining some space in the center some
more influence by the black pawns
and uh yeah this combo of the two white
knights right now
perfectly
defensive pieces but they can also leap
forward later on to attack
and uh yeah from my experience here i'm
never comfortable with the black side
but then again with white sometimes the
thing is what do you do next when do you
push in the center when do you attack
the black king there's so many questions
and okay magnus he's the expert let's
trust him for now and the black queen
just sidestepping anish it looks like he
has done his homework very well however
continuing the pace just bringing his
bishop
out there maybe eyeing up that black
knight what do you think guys if you get
a chance with white will you take it
okay it's run away the question has been
answered for us yeah retreating the
night
okay limiting white's options
yeah i mean it seems like this is fairly
standard stuff as you mentioned um
white wants to get this chance to attack
i guess on the king side and maybe white
has an extra pawn break generally um
with the idea of pushing the c pawn and
then pushing in the center
and it kind of seems in these positions
even though they're equal it's the side
with the more possibilities which has
the easier game and maybe the better
chances here uh but i would have thought
magnus would be just comfortable because
you know he had a world championships uh
defending this this kind of uh structure
so um and he and he knows the niche
needs to win so he doesn't need to
push it too much yeah and meanwhile
anish does bring his bishop out maybe
trying to eliminate a key defender of
the black king the reason white has
maybe a tiny advantage in these types of
positions is because this bishop is
usually so strong we often call it the
spanish bishop because in this opening
this is the key piece if black can trade
it off or kick it back then black's
normally doing okay but right now it
sits on a great diagonal against the
black king and for example if black is a
bit
too careless and just makes a
kind of nothing move a move that doesn't
improve his position you could well see
a trade on this square and suddenly the
white knights might jump forward towards
the black king um also there's a nice
hole in the centre of the board a nice
outpost potentially for white knights
later in the game meanwhile magnus
forcing the black uh the white bishop
sorry to commit he's pushed the pawn
forward and uh if we catch up with the
current position yeah he's attacking the
uh the dart squad bishop now
to take or not to take that is the
question
if you take yes you gain access to this
square but at least
short term maybe black is okay no direct
threats but if you step back that would
allow the possibility at least of black
pushing forward and trapping the white
bishop on the edge of the board this is
always a dilemma this is one of the
things i still struggle with i think
i've struggled with since i was five
years old when do you push this pawn
forward and trap the bishop because it
does allow potential sacrifices it's
very like the world championships there
was a moment when uh jan
uh well i think yam was with the black
pieces even and they had this idea where
magnus could have done the same thing
and sacrificed the piece but i i kind of
you know i like the way anisha's playing
but with this last night maneuver trying
to bring it into that massive square in
the middle of the board and it's finding
those weakened squares maneuvering
around but
this would probably well this would work
against me but these things rarely work
against someone like magnus carlsen you
you can't slow maneuver magnus in these
kind of positions from from experience i
mean uh
let's see just wondering now because the
night has kind of retreated and so i'm
looking at this position i'm going
you step backwards i go forward i mean
is there any way that
black could start
advancing any of his pawns maybe even
i'm just the moves i'm thinking about is
maybe even pushing the c5 point it might
be a bit too creative for my own good
and then the whole idea is once pawn
takes pawn then you go knight um to
attack the bishop okay wow interesting
so hitting this bishop yeah and now
hitting this pawn as well and if white
continues and takes this black pawn
white might be a pawn up temporarily but
after this trade
then we see these two double pawns it's
the theme of today two doubled weak
pawns and black does have the bishop
pair as well to target these pawns later
really interesting there your anchor so
this is definitely on magnus's radar
personally i think he's not going to
touch these pawns i think he'll be
reluctant to do that just because this
pawn formation which we actually see in
the english opening is kind of known as
the botvinic setup magnus is the big
expert here he loves this pawn structure
from the sicilian defense as well he
gets it very regularly there but also in
this uh in this opening the spanish
we've seen him time and time again with
the black pieces just keep this pawn
structure maybe plug this hole by using
a knight later on just retreating that
maybe even at the right moment offering
a trade of bishops and he loves to
organize this pawn push later on f5
so it might involve a slow plan pushing
this pawn forward dropping back the
bishop maybe getting the king out the
way but magnus i think long term would
love to just keep the tension and then
later push this pawn forward another
game springs to mind from last season of
the tour when magnus beat levon ironian
in an almost identical pawn structure
so uh this move it might well be good
but it feels to me as if it's just not
magnus's usual plan so maybe he'll buck
the trend here and try something
different but if not then he might just
maintain the tension and continue
maneuvering a move such as this one is
what i expect at least
and i think ty's calculations are
uh final now for round 15.
this is uh the situation so uh 11
players are fighting for those eight
spots in the quarter finals three
players are 100 safe no pognyarchy
carlsen and artemyev
and 92 almost 93 percent chance for eric
hansen to qualify uh before then anish
giri 28.2
chance and tai did tell us that it is a
must-win situation for anish in this
game and can we see that by his play
that he's just taking risks
no big risks no big risks yet should he
take bigger risks basically i think the
opening choice was wrong
yeah i mean as we say magnus carlsen had
this in the world championships
anisha is just playing his normal kind
of style but can you beat magnus on a
good day in this kind of structure i i
don't see it happening uh i'm saying
that this last move uh playing the
knight into the center of the board is
something i certainly did not expect
magnus to play
but it makes some sense because if the
knight is captured you stop the maneuver
that white was banking on playing so you
take away the the knight square on e3
and maybe we can just sort of shout out
on the board
so i guess i guess that's why magnus has
taken the opportunity to play a little
bit of activity here
yeah i think this would be a strategic
mistake actually to capture in the
center now because yes black gets
doubled pawns but black also gets access
to a semi-open file and this guy is
actually a backward pawn on the c2
square but also as simon mentioned more
importantly
not just this but the white knight lacks
a way to maneuver into the center so i'm
expecting to see maybe
just the white bishop move this bishop
is under fire after all anderson showed
um okay he does take oh wow i was going
to say maybe just plant it in the center
of the wood later use your knight to
back it up but he does capture on the d4
square and surprising moves all around
for me because uh taken with the e pawn
i mean like
really i mean again normally capture
towards the center all right so uh david
said you've got the open c file where
the queen is why why why why are you
taking this way around it's
this is his idea i guess he's going c4
but
really did not expect any of this yeah
he wants to use all these pawns and just
launch them forward to destabilize white
but white got the bishop out of the way
before it got trapped
i don't i never liked taking the e pawn
as black personally because it always
gives white the chance to push the f
pawn at some stage and those two pawns
well i know them very well because uh a
chestable course i did recently the you
know british grand prix this is the
structure of the dutch these two pawns
work so well together and maybe even the
white knight can come out g3 to h5 and i
don't know i don't know if i like this
from black yeah it feels like magnus is
trying to be ambitious as well and maybe
that will backfire
meanwhile i'm surprised by every single
move in this game this one as well a bit
loose
the general rule is don't touch pawns on
the side where you're weaker and here
this is where black is trying to push
black is the one initiating the play so
for white to push his pawn forward as
well
very very surprising
i guess he just wants to clarify the
situation with these two black pawns and
most likely magnus will decide to push
and uh we will see a situation where any
end game might just be winning for black
because okay he doesn't do this i was
going to say this pawn is a potential
target later on but then again black
cannot access this open file because
white's bishop stops the rook uh using
it so okay therefore magnus decides not
to clarify the tension and he wants to
trade the bishops off
we might well see a situation after a
trade like this night against bishop
but with a really weird pawn structure
it seems like they're playing quite
quick and i i feel that maybe is the
nerves we talked about that you know
there's there's been this drama going on
recently is also been very stressful on
a nation and and probably on magnus as
well and
you know when you're more nervous you
tend to play quicker and it just feels
like they're making these big decisions
very quickly even at the level they're
at uh making these decisions i don't
know
it seems a bit strange making them yeah
at this speed and kind of the the sin
that i was thinking about seven deadly
sins that uh david did some little promo
videos for well it kind of here it's
like it feels like both sides are kind
of being quite egoistic you know they're
just thinking about what they want and
they're kind of allowing emotions as
well as nervous nervousness they both
want to win they both want to show that
they're better and so i i don't know
because otherwise why make those moves
so quickly they're important decisions
maybe magnus just wants to have some
rest
you know yeah it's very possible with me
looking he really he really does seem a
bit tired today and he's qualified so uh
it might just be like right i just want
to rest uh get ready for get ready for
the next day um but there's a decision
to be made here right from white i mean
does white can white grab this pawn is
that completely crazy no it probably is
because you can't open up d3 but
uh i i don't know maybe this b3 move
from a niche was just a waste of time it
seems
yeah that's a good question though simon
white why can't well grab a pawn and i
kind of just ruled it out very quickly
but the more i look at it the more i
think maybe it's possible white could
just grab this pawn now it would at
least justify his last move right it
would at least be consistent and after a
trade here
and another capture white does have
these two ugly pawns and as you
mentioned this d3 move pushing the black
pawn forward at some point might well
become relevant just opening up this
bishop to attack a rook in the corner
but then again the rook will just move
at some point and uh i'm not sure black
has full compensation here so maybe
black will keep this one in reserve
maybe activate his rook bring it in at
some point maybe swing this rook across
and magnus i guess he's just not being
too materialistic he's just hoping uh
hoping that the position will open up
for the bishops
and okay meanwhile we didn't see that
happen we do see a trade instead
so a real central pawn mass here for
black it's a bit of a weird
structure but then again this knight at
least for now is a passive piece yep
i mean another idea did why it's too
late now but i i was thinking if magnus
was white what would magnus do and i'm
sure magnus maybe even considering that
last position b takes b takes knight d2
because one thing i noticed is magnus is
so good at finding squares for his
knights and uh you're playing with this
knight against the the dark square
bishop that also seemed very promising
positional way to play but maybe not
enough to win and that's what anisha is
thinking maybe anisha thinking right i
need to take that bishop like i did in
the game because i need to create more
imbalance
but you shouldn't be playing this
opening if you need to create a lot of
imbalances the the other argument about
that yeah exactly so actually he goes
for a similar idea to yours but uh
slightly less forcing at least he's
still putting some pressure on this pawn
uh indirectly he wants to capture it
with his own pawns first but now if
black blocks it up which i think
probably magnus is reluctant to do then
the white knight will recentralize
itself and this bishop is just a bad
piece staring at its own pawns it's
completely blocked no future for that
piece
so i think magnus will be reluctant
definitely to push this pawn forward
there's arguments though to be made for
opening up one file at least or possibly
even push a pawn in the center this is
very risky i'm not sure black's entirely
ready for this but
i mean it just looks nice right having
as many pawns as possible this pawn mass
in the middle of the board and the
reason i say it's risky is because
white's queen could come out maybe
attacking the base of the pawn chain
that would be a check and uh black's
pawns are a bit loose i'm not sure
uh magnus will go for this lock it down
lock it down wow it's a little bit
surprising on every turn putting your
pawns on the same kind of squares your
bishop is not supposed to be a good idea
because your bishop gets more blocked in
uh but he does get a load of space over
there so i guess it's one one you know
one exchange for another but still a bit
surprising there yeah for me it was
quite natural i have to say i mean i was
banking on the fact that the bad bishop
is a good defensive bishop and uh
you know maybe there's some action along
the open line um
and also remember
magnus just needs a draw
and why not uh simplify the position a
little bit and
okay here we go wow bad bishop
extraordinaire yeah
he doesn't care about his bishop he's
just got to go before he's done the
perfect
perfect pattern
everything on the dart squares yeah look
at this
i mean he really he's really lucky white
doesn't have a light squared bishop
otherwise this would be disaster
i mean if white can ever get his knight
in the game somehow white white should
probably win this but
is there any way white can ever get the
knight in i mean you know you put the
knight in the center of the board here
game over but uh
maybe you just can't maneuver the knight
i mean you have to create some
weaknesses somewhere f5 maybe as a
square but i don't know it's it seems
like uh
only white is the one who might have
has chances here i should say yeah um i
mean black's avenue of attack will be
this file if you can somehow sneak his
rook in later but white won't abandon
that anytime soon
and another plan for white could just be
an end game for example you could move
your rook across and if black just for
example waits or locks it down and you
could bring your queen back and at some
point aim to trade off this side a set
of rooks
for example like this take take and then
offer another trade
if you can get all the rooks off you'll
be very happy with white but maybe the
problem is that black will just park a
rook on a square where you don't really
want to capture it because this would
just allow a very powerful past pawn so
it's really really interesting
strategically it's not clear what either
side's plans are or what they want to
achieve long term but
either way still a lot of life left
yeah and anish may be a bit nervous
dropping lower on the clock than magnus
and in the end just playing an innocent
pawn move okay magnus going for a
similar idea to the one i mentioned he
wants to take over on this a file before
white does
yes maybe white plays h4 h5 knight g4 f4
sorry there's too many a lot of moves
there but you try to do something on the
king side from the white the white uh
perspective and you try to use the light
squares on the king side because black
can't control the light squares on the
king side because everything's on dark
squares and one thing to bear in mind if
you put all your pawns on one color
square and black's done that he's put
all of his pawns on dark squares it
naturally makes the opposite color
squares weak the light squares so you
can just aim to target them and that's
what he's going for so he's going for
eight this pawn push and going to try to
put those uh well look i did beat magnus
when he's 10 years old
i know i know how to beat the kid oh
yeah unlike some of us
yeah that was impressive you've also
sprinkled your magic dust on all the
players every game today we've seen the
move h4 at some point
on that subject of h4 uh houston's after
actually tweeted us a super cool poem
about harry and uh you can see on the
board there's been a rick exchange and i
guess there was a small porn once named
harry
who had the whole white team to carry he
ran down his line and felt mighty fine
when he turned queen and looked like a
fairy that's pretty good beautiful nice
work
nice work yeah wow you should write that
out and hang it on your wall simon yeah
definitely the weirdest idea i had
actually was i wanted to send harry to
space and i saw you could get these it's
like balloons that go into the
stratosphere yeah yeah and i wanted to
attach a camera to a balloon i wanted to
get a little harry to send him up into
space
maybe one day crowdfunding it would be
quite good footage for the show yeah
yeah it could be
a a lone harry would just be a porn
so
it would be a little hairy venturing
into space first harry into space
so you know you can buy you know you can
buy stars right you can buy you can yeah
it's kind of cheating oh but whoa we
have a result you guys
andreas penco
has won the game against levon aronian
and that must mean that essepenko
is qualified i think
quite certain but does it also mean that
levon aronian is out
yeah maybe not 100 sure but it's uh
not looking good then for the one wow
wow and only 20 moves levon making a
massive blunder early in the game with
white
you rarely see that but fair play to
esopenko he spotted a mistake it wasn't
obvious and he pounced to win that game
so uh meanwhile in this one still
maneuvering around black has conquered
this a file with the black rook with the
black queen but what to do with it that
is the big question white's knight
meanwhile very very stuck
i i have an idea what to do with the
with the a-line but it doesn't involve
the queen or the rook it involves the
king
i think the king can snake his way
gets the king all the way to that dark
square which is b4 that would be that
would be phenomenal actually pretty
pretty good idea right because you can
go all the endings are probably quite
nice and i think i mean what magnus has
done here i mean
we mentioned a niche has this control on
the king side but open files are so
important and magnus controls that open
file um
okay he's got to get this i reckon the
queens are going to try to come off and
then
you know once the coast is clear
[Laughter]
all right well oh the bar jumps up a
little bit for anish
with one game finished i just want to
take a quick look at the live table
especo winning that game gaining three
points
um i think we can get the live table up
to see the situation right now so yeah
with all the other games still going on
that's panko in second place and where
is levon seventh place but then anish
giri can overtake him dingley rank can
uh go past him
it's not looking good for levon oronian
all right and also i'm very interested
in eric hansen of course because i think
he only needs to get a draw but i might
be wrong we need our stats guy but if he
wins he certainly goes through so uh
which would be great for his you know
his team of streamers online i mean
that'd be that'd be amazing i think you
only have five percent chance that he
too to qualify when he started yeah so
that'd be tremendous result incredible
performance yeah all right a bunch of
moves happening here do you see chances
for niche to win this definitely some
chances um i'm very surprised i must
admit by this king march yes it's the
artistic way to do it but black's king
is not entirely safe on this side of the
board
and it does feel like white's queen is
going to cause a lot of annoyance over
the next few turns unless black can get
the queens off i think anish might be
the one having the fun and look what
white's done he's put his pawn on b4
before the black king can get there and
uh yeah it just feels
a bit scary now from the black side if
the white knight can somehow join the
action it's still not easy to do that
but simon may be mapped one path the
white knight at some point might drop
back and to the hd square jump to g4 i
mean i think you have to look at pawn
breaks don't you and
at some point maybe this knight coming
back and pushing the f pawn it just
seems like a very natural way to play on
the king side and now
now that black doesn't control that a
file anymore now that black's king can
always be checked as it has had to
material
it seems like there's even whatever the
computer says there's quite a lot of
danger uh for magnus in this position
because
he
he has to be very careful yeah will we
see a repetition of the position black
is offering the queen trade
anish has to decide now if you take the
queens off that will only favor black
and that is because this pawn is on a
dark square black might pick it off
later in the game so anish cannot swap
queens he wants to keep the queens on
but if he retreats with a check this is
blocked if he goes forward with the
check this is blocked and that would
repeat the position
let's go back to the players if he wants
to win okay he does keep the queens on
the board right no queen trade
and now he's controlling the some more
squares on the king side this uh
maybe important square g4 that the
knight can try to get into to pressurize
black's king's side i mean i think this
is very uncomfortable for black this
position and i don't think the computer
maybe gives it enough enough justice uh
how tricky it is to defend from black's
point of view aneesh must be happy here
surely yeah in the position i i just
don't understand this king maneuver why
is the king not back where it started
why did the queen not just put himself
on light squares earlier stopping
white's queen getting in now white's
queen is in
it's all sorts of trouble for black and
uh okay he's still solid for now
everything's protected this rook retreat
just over guarding this central pawn but
it's uh yeah it's looking good for anish
if he can somehow enact one of these two
plans bringing the knight back leaping
it forward or maybe even pushing this
pawn now to open up some lines but you
have to be careful david because uh
magnus's move looks like it was just a
retreating move but it did contain a
threat which is basically to step the
queen back and offer a trade
and uh just try to pester anish with
that offer of queen trade okay but then
there would just be a check and oops not
that check
this check and white's queen could
escape the trade so okay he goes for the
second plan the safer plan i don't think
you need to rush with this move you want
to prepare it first he drops his knight
back it's just torture for black it's
absolute torture because you can see
black is just
losing a move white improves losing a
move why it improves this just seems
like incredibly tough though i mean uh
you know when the knight gets this
square it's heading for white can push
at the right moment i just hate to be
black in this position
yeah fully agreed and magnus continuing
this dance with the queen's trying and
hoping praying that they come off the
board but anish will try and keep them
on if he can
and uh he would love to keep the queen
on this diagonal if possible in order to
stop the black rook coming back down and
threatening some pawns do you agree with
the bar saying 1.4 advantage quite a big
advantage for a niche
i mean here in this type of position i
think we would just discuss grandmasters
we would just say it's easier to play
with white white is the one who can take
the draw at any moment if he wants black
is the one struggling and defending i'm
not sure that would translate into a
kind of concrete physical advantage in
terms of winning material or winning a
pawn being plus one up but it's
definitely easier to play with white
okay but repeating the position this is
the second time we've seen this position
okay anish needs to find a different
square for the white queen
ah i
if he takes the draw and then gets
eliminated i think he will live to
regret it so yeah um he should keep the
queens on at least play on a bit longer
i don't think he will take the draw i
think we're safe there i think he will
oh has he's taken a trial well
really what okay magnus meanwhile
smiling a niche wow bailing out with the
draw he could have kept the game going
another 20 30 moves and then gone for
the same draw yeah
you can just yeah just keep the queen
going blacks